et
eh bien
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour beau temps à paris aujourd'hui
pour le défilé du 14 juillet sur les
champs elysées vous le verrez le résumé
filmées de ce défilé dans un astre
l'actualité est celle d'un jour de
vacances beaucoup de noyades d'
accidents de la route en france
les bals du 14 juillet à paris on
s'était quelque peu perturbée par des
bagarres provoqué lit-on par des
maoïstes
à l'étranger la plupart des chefs d'état
ont envoyé aujourd'hui des messages de
félicitations au président pompidou à
l'occasion de la fête nationale
française
la situation est calme en irlande israël
propose des contacts secrets à l'egypte
il n'y a pas encore de réponse du côté
égyptien c'est tout ce que l'on peut
retenir ce matin laissons maintenant
jean pierre lannes nous présentait les
moments les plus importants du défilé
militaire de ce matin sur les
champs-elysées à paris
et c'est à 10h précises car la dernière
mesure de la marseillaise commence ce
défilé du 14 juillet
survolant la tribune les premiers
appareils de l'armée de l'air au fret un
panache tricolore aux parisiens venus
non
tandis que le président de la république
une chose georges pompidou avait pris
place à la tribune officielle quelques
minutes auparavant
avant cette cérémonie le président décor
est sur le front des troupes général
fourquet et monsieur ponchon anciens
combattants de 39 40
le président de la république avait à
ses côtés juge avant les masses monsieur
michel devrait et les présidents des
assemblées messieurs polaire et peretti
le corps diplomatique au grand complet
était conduit par son doyen le nonce
apostolique
comme le veut la tradition ce furent les
troupes motorisées blindé qui se
présente elle est première devant la
tribune présidentielle
précédé par un peloton de gendarmes
motocyclistes
non
le gouverneur militaire de paris le
général m se plaçait alors face à la
tribune officielle
après le 501e combat suivant le 1er
régiment battait marine équipés de
buziet 255 monté sur chat est aussi le
501e des combats puis les abusif
obus de 155
mais l un des passages les plus
attendues lé fut celui des éléments de
l'artillerie entière habitude de 30 que
voici autotracté équipés de radars et de
calculateurs électro
vient ensuite les missiles sol air hawks
et puis derrière sur la rampe de
lancement les airs fin avions sans
pilote de reconnaissance
puis pour la première fois montré au
public des éléments de notre deuxième
génération de force 10 10 est des
missiles stratégiques et des engins de
servitude de 18 mètres 60 véhicules
également porter d'ogives nucléaires
les voici
je rappelle c'est la première fois qu'un
tel armement étaient déclassifiés et
montrer au public et cette arme sera
opérationnel l'an prochain
et terminant ce premier défilé les prix
augmentent et motorisé apparaissait la
garde républicaine
garde républicaine suivi par les troupes
à pied elle même mené par deux
compagnies de l'école polytechnique a eu
pour la première fois des fils et aussi
les sous mariniers dollar études et de
l'espagne
et le défilé touchante assad pour fermer
la marche la légion qui n'avait pas
défilé pour le 14 juillet depuis quatre
et dix mille soldats 655 véhicules 161
avions voilà l'effectif des troupes ont
pu voir les parisiens à l'occasion de ce
qu'attend russe
comme au ralenti les sables horta vidéo
est là
à 11 heures tout était terminé et
monsieur georges pompidou rogan y est
allé pour palais de l'elysee tandis que
des milliers de parisiens et de
touristes de se disperser alors des
parisiens et des touristes venus
nombreux pour comme dit la chanson
acclamé voir et complimenter l'armée
française
un reportage maintenant sur les balles
de la nuit dernière à paris où vous
savez que certains de ces balles ont été
marqués par des bagarres il a eu des
bagarres également à grenoble la suite
en images les français ont dansé hier
soir sur les places publiques dans les
bals populaires fidèle à une tradition
qui n'avait rien perdu de son charme
sauf à paris peut-être où les
noctambules on tue la nostalgie des
p'tit bal de quartier populeux qui avait
disparu malgré le départ d'un grand
nombre de vacanciers il y avait
néanmoins beaucoup de monde dans les
rues et très tard à l'exception de la
place de la bastille où des incidents
provoqués par des groupes de jeunes
gauchistes ont interrompu les festivités
la place était ensuite étroitement gardé
par les forces de l'ordre aussi bien
qu'elle n'avait pas son visage habituel
du 14 juillet au grand regret des
nombreux parisiens qui étaient venus se
distraire
à l'occasion du 14 juillet le journal
officiel publie une liste de promotion
et de nomination dans l'ordre de la
légion d'honneur et nous avons relevé
les noms parmi les promus au grade
d'officier d'elvire popesco de jean
carzou comme officier eugène ionesco et
raymond kopa comme chevalier nouvelles
de l'étranger maintenant en irlande du
nord le déchaînement de la violence le
déchaînement de violence que l'on
craignait à l'occasion du défilé
orangistes d'hyères son registre sont
les protestants ce déchaînement de
violence n'a pas su lier un reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux
contrairement à toute attente en effet
les manifestations orangistes se sont
déroulées hier dans le plus grand calme
revenus à leur point de départ après
avoir parcouru plus de 20 kilomètres
dans les rues de belfast
les protestants se sont dispersés en fin
d'après midi évitant soigneusement toute
manifestation susceptible de provoquer
les réactions du côté catholique
c'est donc avec soulagement que
l'irlande du nord s'est endormi cette
nuit un soulagement partagé bien sûr par
l'armée et par la police qui n'ont pas
eu à intervenir
mais aussi par tous ceux qui ont suivi
avec inquiétude les préparatifs et le
déroulement de ces fêtes à la fin du
défilé claude manuel a demandé à un
pasteur et un orangistes quels étaient
les craintes et les espoirs des
protestants d'irlande du nord
ils veulent retenir des situations comme
il existe et qui sait
et aveugle au futur ils ont une crainte
d'une association avec le sucre parce
qu'il craque
ici c'est une gouvernement va être
compliqué une peuple avec une ville
différente avec une une fois différente
avec sauce et asocial différentes et il
il a eu une crainte de cette cet état ne
pensez-vous pas que dans le faste que
l'on déploie que déploient les
protestants cette occasion il y à une
sorte de provocation à l'égard des
catholiques à dans les processions les 8
même si une catholique de pétrole
provoquée
oui parce que autour de la procession il
y a oh que deux jeunes filles qui
jouaient et qui crient des contrôles et
catholiques et c c'est les jeunes qui
suivent la procession qui sont critiques
cause la provocation
au fond la question n'est pas une
question religieuse
c'est une question politique et sociale
il peut se résoudre ce qui pouvait se
résoudre
la bonne volonté combien d'années l'île
de jersey a également connu des moments
difficiles
l'économie de cette il repose sur le
tourisme mais cette année les touristes
ont failli être chassé par les
immondices
en effet les éboueurs étaient en grève
état de siège dans l'île anglo normande
de jersey où l'on avait perdu l'habitude
des grèves depuis la dernière en 1926 or
celle ci a surpris tout le monde à
commencer par l'honorable président de
l'assemblée jersey yens philippe raud
m'real dont les ancêtres débarquèrent de
normandie en landes 12 109 ces gens ici
ils n'ont et non ils ont fait une grève
qui n'est pas officiel si ces gens ici
avait fait avec officiel eh bien on sait
s'il est regrettable on le referee
discussions le référencement mais que
l'on fait c'est si il se change en
mirent en grève sans faire ni dire
pourquoi l'objet du scandale le voici
ses poubelles abandonnées pour un
problème de salaires dans les rues de la
ville considérée comme la plus propre du
monde
le conflit dans gagner les transports
donc le ravitaillement un mouvement de
panique a failli gagner les insulaires
mais nous sommes heureux d'annoncer à
messieurs les touristes que les choses
sont aujourd'hui rentré dans l'ordre et
qu'ils peuvent à nouveau gagné jersey
sans craindre pour leur salut
les ministres de l'agriculture des six
réunis à bruxelles ont accepté les
propositions de la commission du marché
commun concernant le rattrapage
progressif que doivent effectuer les
prises agricole français à la suite de
la dévaluation du franc de l'an dernier
les prix français seront augmentés à la
fin du mois dans la proportion suivante
graines oléagineuses et sucre 2 pour
sembler 3% orgie seigle et 4% maïs
quatre et demi pour cent et riz 12 et
demi pour cent ce dernier produit
rattrape ainsi le prix communautaires
pour le beurre et la viande bovine les
prix resteront inchangés on sait d'autre
part que les produits agricoles se sont
de plus en plus souvent transportés en
avion et à cette fin la hérault gard
d'orly a été obligé de moderniser et
d'agrandir ses installations destinées à
recevoir le ferai cette modernisation
est l'objet de reportages que vous allez
voir m
la semaine dernière à orly un acholi
s'évader de la gare du fret
après neuf heures de safari 30 gendarmes
capturé dans un champ de blé ce colis
bucolique en chiffres pour l'aéroport de
paris ce colis un guépard en provenance
de djibouti est noyée parmi les 260
milles tonnes de fret transitant chaque
année sur les aéroports d'orly et du
bourget car l'important dans ce trafic
du fret croît de façon spectaculaire
cinquante mille tonnes il y a huit ans
deux cent soixante mille aujourd'hui et
plus de 2 millions prévus pour 1981
d'ailleurs roissy est conçu pour traiter
plus de 4 millions de tonnes
une croissance d'elle que très bientôt
lorsque le trafic fret sera l'égal du
trafic passagers qu'on envisage la
création d'aéroport et si le transport
de fret deviendra équivalent au
transport passagers vers la fin de ce
siècle
on envisage même je crois la création
d'un aéroport spécialement pour le fret
oui de nombreuses études sont faites à
ce sujet aéroport spécialisé également
utilisation d'hydravion gérant diverses
études dans ce sens en fait et parfois
les petits guépards qui s'échappe sur la
piste d'orly poursuivi par les gendarmes
est ce que c'est ce genre d'incidents
qui arrive de temps en temps comme dans
toute activité d'exploitation
oui heureusement car la capacité d'un
boeing 747
en plus de ses passagers est l'égal de
celles des modernes avion cargo est à ce
sujet précisons que la moitié du
transport aérien des marchandises est
encore effectués par des avions de
passagers mais prévoyant l'avenir orly
fred s'agrandit et ce mécanisme il n'a
qu'à la quatrième place mondiale
derrière new york londres et francfort
mais ambitionne troisième rang
industriels et commerçants sont en effet
séduit par ce moyen de transport rapide
et efficace les fleurs coupées le matin
hollande sont en vente à midi à rungis
et la côte d'azur fait venir ses
langoustes du canada un jour même un
douanier horrifié découvrit qu'un
container de vêtements appartenant à un
mexicain renfermait en réalité toute sa
famille momifié
quant à ces charmants dauphin nous ne
connaissons pas encore suffisamment leur
langage pour savoir s'il apprécie ce
moyen de transport
mais si vos moyens sont inférieures à
vos besoins
allez vous promener du côté des
entreprises il y traînent parfois 250
kilos d'or voilà les mauvais conseils
que vous ne suivrez certainement pas
l'actualité sportive maintenant la 18e
étape du tour de france qui mène les
coureurs de saint gaudens à la mongie
secours a aujourd'hui elle comporte de
nombreuses difficultés avec l'ascension
du col d'aspe aspects comme on dit dans
la région et l'arrivée au sommet jugé
sur les pentes du tourmalet en tennis
cet après-midi finale européenne de la
coupe davis à barcelone entre l'espagne
et la yougoslavie avec deux matchs au
rang s contre spire suivi de santana
contre franulovic l'espagne favorite
contre la yougoslavie telemedia terminer
je vous remercie de votre attention et
vous souhaite de passer une excellente
après-midi en voir
et
m